you had bunch of fights in UFC by the
way but make sure that I don't forget to
tell the kill jock with story I got to
tell that story later but I'll just tell
her right now
well I'll see but but um okay so I was
not I mean there wasn't pride at the
time Chako went to Afghanistan plummet
to run for a couple months and then it
was maybe I was just doing no longer
maybe I'm not sure but you were gone and
you come back and my mom had this
medication I had acne and thought it was
some kinda antibiotic helped it but I
didn't know it made me really weak and
took my endurance away this is actually
true this is not an excuse it sure is so
Junko comes back and I'm not really
feeling that good chocolate strain I'm
like okay chocolate that kicks my ass
and choc was like literally he's angry
is like you lazy mother I'm in the
desert I'm doing this and you you're
sitting on your ass here and standing or
do nothing and I kick your ass and what
and I'm like yeah I'm just like I just
like it I'm not ashamed of myself
because and then you go away for like a
month if somewhere you're gone and I'm
like and I met a case we were ten days
and I stopped and I feel strong again
I'm like oh I understand now so I'm
training I'm like motherland comes back
I can't wait for this I made a CD kill
Jacko's and it was I had like Korn and
Metallica Saul he's like mr. Jang came
and I'm like hey cha go and I put this
Indian and then we train him that was my
day yes I think I was like talking [ __ ]
dude like you my feelings were hurt
and here's what sucks everybody is so if
if both of us are on point I'm get I'm
catching a beatdown
if but so both of us are bringing our
a-game I'm catching a beatdown
if Dean's bring in his a-game and I'm
bringing my week game I'm catching a
beatdown
if I'm bringing my full a game and
Dean's having a horrible day
I do like barely okay so it's like every
day's the day the really good days that
I have are very few I have to I have to
earn them I'll put the tea that way I
have to earn them
and then so you do UFC you do decent UFC
you had some tough fights I was a good
fight three for ranked in my division
milah my only two losses my decision was
Nate Marquardt and you should know
economy and they both after that fight
fire and it's the silver so I was two
times right there front for the belt I
was top five top no I don't care tops it
but I fought to fight in silver I lost
both those matches but the four I want
and my first fight was at least the
Sokka I was from Italy's really tough
fighter fat yeah probably the fastest
hands and actually I figure this out
later I was the underdog but they were
actually trying to feed me to him he was
gonna fight chuckle Italian or
stepping-stone
Oh supposedly yes most and this group
they're already planning like he's gonna
fight chocolate delicacy guys probably
fight he has faster hands he'd probably
chuck has a really good chin better
wrestling but saqqara faster hands
better boxing so I'll have them fight
after that's what I heard
but that day I got in the same triangle
guys showed you a carrion and but he
topped showed you here went to sleep so
both my debuts were won by the same move
and it's tough guys so then I fight uh
another Japanese opponent I fight a
Bulgarian Olympic wrestler I fought Nate
Marquardt you should have caught me and
I fought Jeremy Horn so six fights in
USC so you're my career has been focused
on jiu-jitsu more nogi is because when
you do MMA you don't you don't have a
gear or chemo on so it kind of wasting
your time if you're training and that
aspect and you don't have a gear on you
can how to grab the belt how to do this
kind of wasting your time so yeah I've
distributed my time between mixed
martial arts and grappling